[Music]
hey everybody its charlie happy
comic-con a week they just dropped
another aquaman preview with the actors
and the director talking about the movie
explaining the characters some of the
backstory where it fits into the DC
universe and how they incorporated the
comics so we gotta break all this down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the
comic-con videos even though this is
Aquaman I'll do a new round of the flash
ring giveaway it would normally be movie
tickets but the movies not coming out to
December so all you've to do to enter
that is be a subscriber leave a comment
on the video the big thing first this
takes place after the events of Justice
League I think everybody assume that
it's still a shared movie universe but
the movie itself is meant to be
self-contained so if there are any
post-credit stingers or any tags that
set up other DC movies it's only gonna
be for the Aquaman sequel so it's not
like they're gonna be trying to set up
Man of Steel 2 or the next Wonder Woman
movie or Shazam or the flash movie I
think everybody assumed that they
weren't gonna be setting up the next
Batman movie just because that's
supposed to be a prequel the way they
described the tone in the feel of the
movie is Raiders of the Lost Ark meets
Romancing the Stone so this is it it's
not any kind of like romantic comedy or
anything like that but in the way that
Raiders of the Lost Ark is this big
swashbuckling adventure that's mostly
with the film is James Wan the director
is mostly known for his horror films
like the conjuring franchise the Saw
films when they go to trench he says
they went full Creature from the Black
Lagoon and he did explain some of the
technicalities in the mythology so the
reason why Aquaman is so strong in white
Atlanteans in general are much stronger
than humans is because their bodies have
evolved to survive at that pressure
depth so like Black Manta who's a normal
human has to wear that special pressure
suit they also explained the origin of
black manta to within the DC EU they do
Aquaman's origin story through
flashbacks but they're also doing a
version of black mantas origin story so
if you have an idea for what Aquaman was
doing before the events of Justice
League before Batman tracked him down he
was just taking down pirates but the
people of Atlantis didn't want him the
surface world didn't want him so he was
just kind of blowing around the ocean by
himself a loner trying to take down
pirates black mantas father appears in
the film when the film picks up their
pirate
he develops a special relationship with
ocean master I'll explain why in a
second but it's pretty self-evident so
Black Manta is big mission during the
film he's a minor character but a
relatively important one is that he just
wants to kill Aquaman they explained
that he doesn't want to take over the
world he doesn't have grand ambitions
he's just out for revenge
they didn't say exactly why but I think
it's pretty easy to guess if his father
is in the film and he and his father are
both pirates
Aquaman hates pirates at some point
before the events of a Batman V Superman
or Justice League Aquaman probably took
down their pirate vessel and wound up
killing black mantas father they did say
that Black Manta would have two
different comic-book costumes so I'm
assuming that he's just going to
streamline what his eventual special
comic-book helmet looks like the funny
thing too is that James Wan said Oh
we'll let you know why the eyes are red
it's not just to make it look cool but
if you've read the comics or you've
watched Young Justice you know that they
give off energy blast
so the thing about Aquaman 2 is they
said they didn't want to make him just
like Superman because aside from his
ability to talk to fish and his
abilities when he's in water he does
feel a lot like the Superman character
in the comics at times so the way they
explained Aquaman's powers is that just
as an Atlantean he has a naturally
enhanced physiology that's evolved to
live at that depth what that translates
to is a very Luke Cage type of explainer
so his skin is very resilient like his
muscles will stop bullets but bullets
can penetrate his skin so it sounds like
what'll happen is is they'll either be
flashback scenes or there'll be an
action scene on land where a bunch of
people try to shoot him and bullets
don't bounce off of him like they bounce
off of Superman they just stopped dead
in him so they sting a little bit and
piss him off but the only weapons that
can actually legitimately hurt him or in
lanten weapons but remember ocean master
is trying to take over the seven
different kingdoms he's trying to unite
the seven against the surface world
during the movie so ocean master has
everything he needs to take down Aquaman
because like I said remember there's a
Raiders of the Lost Ark element to the
film so we're trying to unite the seven
different kingdoms of Atlantis it's sunk
about five thousand years ago they say
collectively before Atlantis sank there
were about 50 million people living in
the seven different kingdoms
Los Angeles was the reference point that
they used so imagine that Los Angeles is
like a minor city inside this giant
nation of Atlantis but they only say
what five of the seven kingdoms are so
obviously it's Atlantis Zemel Trench
brine they call one the fisherman
kingdom we got a preview for them a
couple days ago this is what they look
like they're fully merpeople but they're
meant to be highly evolved compared to
the Atlanteans so like I've said they've
all evolved to live at that depth but
these people have evolved even more than
that to survive underwater but they
still haven't said what the other three
different kingdoms are so some of the
names of these different seven kingdoms
are different from what they are in the
comics I think I've said before that
they're pulling from Jeff John's new 52
unite the seven comic book story but
they say it's not a direct adaptation of
that but if you didn't read that new 52
story the original king of Atlantis
Aquaman's
ancestor King at LAN was a big character
so I'm guessing Raider to the lost art
style both Aquaman and ocean master
tried to unite the seven for different
reasons are probably looking for
artifacts that belonged to King at land
that will help them unite the seven
different kingdoms small detail but a
pretty big deal they confirmed that the
Quinn dent that he wields during Justice
League is not meant to be the iconic
comic book Trident which he will wield
by the end of the movie the teaser
picture that James Wan released is
actually right out of the comics it's
just a picture of Aquaman in his full
comic book armor raising up this army of
sharks obviously there's the army of
sharks coming in the poster this picture
here seems like it's either a big
flashback to King at land or it's
actually coming from towards the end of
the film when Aquaman gets his comic
book armor you've seen him in the Batman
V Superman armor you saw him in his
Justice League armor which belonged to
the king at land that Zack Snyder
envisioned this guy during that Justice
League flashback sequence is meant to be
the original king of Atlantis so that's
why Automan is wearing his armor in
present day during the film but then on
set we've seen him in chitinous armor so
it looks like he gets a change here but
by the end of the film they did say that
he would get his orange and green comic
book armor they didn't explain how
that's going to happen but I'm guessing
that this teaser picture here that James
Wan tweeted out a little while ago is
what is actually going to look like but
I'm sure there's a thousand other
questions they're gonna drop the full
trailer Saturday morning so of course
I'll do a video for that and we'll do
whatever follow-up videos we need to do
but just in general everybody that
visited the set was pretty hype about
what was going on
compared to Justice League James Wan did
say that one of the big sticking points
for him actually taking the project and
doing the Aquaman movie was that Warner
Brothers would totally let him do his
own thing so he was never going to be
doing the same thing to Zack Snyder or
any of the other DC filmmakers were
gonna do so it is meant to look and feel
very different from all the other DC
movies so it's not gonna be like Wonder
Woman it's not gonna be like Justice
League or Batman V Superman or any of
the Zack Snyder stuff so I think that is
all to its benefit so whatever ends up
happening it will totally be on James
Wan I do have a lot of faith in him I'm
really a big fan of his horror films so
I'm excited to see
see how he incorporates that into this
but post all your theories in the
comments below let me know if there's
any special requests you have from Comic
Con or remind everyone about the video
schedule as we move forward and as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see all the videos so no
worries while you wait for everything
click here for brand new Avengers 4 and
ant-man and the wasp
and click here to watch Tom Hall and
give away some of the plot of Avengers 4
it's actually pretty great thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]